i'm joined today by llamara wien a
former White House correspondent and a
communications expert he focuses on
government Pollock's politics and
diversity it's so great to talk to you
know I'm interested in just sort of
first getting your general sense of when
we talk about the black lives matter
movement uh give me your sense of the
movement as you understand it and then
maybe contrast that if you think there
is a contrast with how the movement is
portrayed in corporate media well I
think first this this began not as much
the movement but these shootings began
with with the shooting the death of
Trayvon Martin in Florida and I think
after that case and the verdict in the
Zimmerman trial they began this movement
the black lives movement where you have
individuals who are concerned about the
shootings of african-american men
primarily we're video cameras were used
and it appeared that there were
alternative methods in terms of
confronting these quote-unquote suspects
so as we progress to Ferguson and also
Baltimore you saw a buildup of tension I
believe within the black community and
you saw the formation of black lives
matter which is a statement that
suggests counter-intuitively of what
we're seeing in these videos that in
those videos that the perception is that
black lives don't matter so I think
after time has gone by this movement has
picked up but as you saw with Dallas you
saw the shooting in Dallas and I think
that that really was a turning point and
that's when people started assuming that
because the shooting happened during the
black lives matter protest that they
were directly involved and and that gave
sort of a black eye to the black lives
matter movement one of the things
I've been looking at recently is for any
movement I want to sort of explore what
are the underlying facts that either
support fully or partially or or not uh
the sort of objectives of the movement
and one of the things I've been very
interested in is this study by the
Harvard economist which uh uh determined
based on his analysis of the data that
while there is no doubt that black men
are over-represented relative to their
population in terms of being the victims
of police shootings that they are
comparatively underrepresented relative
to their respective crime rates and
rates of interactions with police I've
not really heard anything from
individuals associated with black lives
matter sort of specifically addressing
that study what's your sense of how such
a study can impact the sort of broader
public presentation of what an
organization or group like black lives
matter movement I guess is the right way
wants to go forward when you have a
study that says well we need to really
look at the specific data here before we
make the broadest of broad conclusions
with regard to police shootings what I
see from from what I've a watch and
witnessed is is a growing pattern of
these shootings and and then as I
mentioned to you in an email that there
isn't a voice for these African
Americans the legal system has not
provided them any sign of justice and I
want to go directly to the case of Tamir
rice yeah he was 12 years old there was
a call they said that there was a 20
year old man I mean somebody who's 12 it
can't be 20 but these these
misconceptions and stereotypes and and
those elements are controlling or
driving these actions that end up in
deadly force where they didn't need to
be deadly force and in that case there
wasn't any consequences for those
officers
and that I think drives black lives
matter but it also creates a situation
where you and I are having a
conversation we're talking about this
we're not standing on a corner with guns
pointing at each other now so I don't
even own any guns yeah me neither so the
point is that these kind of dialogues
are difficult to have to have and I
think as I've written in the past we
need more black leaders in this country
who are are able to go into these
communities and our respected and who
can speak sort of like Martin Luther
King spoke those days during the civil
rights movement yeah and addressed these
issues I would love to get some advice
from you and I say this not in any sort
of rhetorical sense or sarcastic sense
or whatever but genuinely I'd be curious
to hear from you uh I've been very clear
that the broader goals of what I
understand to be the black lives matter
movement right dealing with issues of
disparities in policing based on race
dealing with issues of disparities in
prosecution based on race and and
including in that I include also F Nyssa
t as well as class there have been
instances where while I'm of course
supportive of that I issue individual
critiques of actions specific actions
taken under the supposed umbrella of
black lives matter and although I feel
that I am being ninety to ninety-five
percent sort of positive with a five to
ten percent critique of a specific
tactic or whatever I've been called
everything up to and including a white
supremacist for having the audacity to
issue any critique of the movement is
there any way you could advise me where
I could make critiques that I feel are
fair and based in fact while not being
branded as a sort of enemy of the
movement because I would like to be able
to find that way alright well first Dave
you know this is a highly emotional
subject even as I prepared to talk with
you I'm thinking about the language that
I'm going to use there's a difference
between you know rational thought and
just pure emotion and
you know I'll give you a quick example I
was in the grocery store yesterday and I
was at the counter and I had a
ten-dollar bill and the lady went to the
customer service counter because she
wanted just to run this black marker
over my ten-dollar bill she didn't
believe it was a real ten-dollar bill
and there were some customers behind me
who were white and they were annoyed and
agitated and they're looking at me like
you gave her a fake ten-dollar bill so
these kind of things happen frequently
at least once a week those kind of
incidents has happened so so you have to
be sensitive about those realities but
I'll also think that there's a practical
approach to this I mean I spoke to the
DOJ about policing doing a doing a
training program that would be a
certificate program for police and that
would you know give them some other
tactics besides using deadly force so
that is a practical approach that's
something that within the co PS program
community officers policing services
that's something that they could
actually do that would solve some of
these issues it's a solution versus a
critique yeah I think I understands that
what you're so you know I'd be
interested in how that applies sort of
to the to the from the journalistic
critiques of black lives matter that may
exist that's so certainly I understand
the analogy in terms of addressing some
of the police centered issues but what
about even in speaking about black lives
matter because what I'm sometimes left
feeling after I speak to individuals who
are critical of my coverage which again
is ninety to ninety-five percent
positive uh I'm I'm left feeling like I
am NOT allowed to issue any critique at
all sometimes because I'm not black
which seems to me like the type of
identity politics that can be very
damaging to some two movements in many
cases yeah and I think again you know
we're able to have a conversation and
discuss these things that's a big step
it's demonstrating your capacity to have
a dialogue with somebody of an African
American background I mean not that such
a huge deal but it is important when i
covered the white house for two and a
half years and and i wrote this piece
and linkedin and
December you know the hill newspaper
refused to publish it Joel Cabot over
there said oh the legal department won't
approve this but it wasn't such a
controversial piece but it was very
frank direct piece about some of the
experiences that I had you know at the
White House over two and a half years
you know African American reporters we
weren't on the shows in CNN and MSNBC
because we didn't get the visibility it
created a situation where eventually we
were no longer there because of funding
and scheduling and other things so i
think when those communities when we're
not allowed to have a voice in that kind
of forum where we have a quote unquote
african-american president then it
creates a void so the guy I was in Texas
makai Johnson he gets his gun and he
looks around he says Oh nobody's talking
on TV about this nobody's representing
us I'm going to go out with a gun and
I'm going to shoot all these people it's
just crazy but that's what happens and I
think we have to be sensitive in right
now I think for the country these
shootings are out of control now but
what Mara to be clear are you saying I
want to make this is super important I
want to make super clear understand this
are you saying that the mica Xavier
Johnson shooting in Texas while it was
horrific you understand why it happened
as a result of what specifically you're
saying lack of diversity in media or I
want to really make sure we all
understand sort of the the dist what
what path you're creating for why not
I'm saying I'm saying that there's a
correlation between the representation
on those talk shows the talk shows in
particular not just reporting you know
Joe reporter at the White House saying
oh I'm here with the president but the
talk shows where these issues are
discussed broadly you know when you look
at a lot of those talk shows and even
those early years of the Obama
administration we were non-existent so
that's a problem because it takes a
group of people out of the discussion
that should be in the discussion so
there were roundtable discussions about
President Obama and how it felt for him
to be
the first african-american president but
we weren't there we weren't in the room
we weren't allowed to go on those
programs and that kind of suppression of
voices is not good it doesn't gel not
suggesting that it's the only reason
that Johnson shooting happened but I do
think it plays a factor and I think
that's why it's important for meet the
press and that's why was critical of
Chuck Todd in particular because I felt
that he had been there at the White
House and he basically ignored all of us
black reporters so to summon that you're
saying lat lack of racial diversity in
talk shows is connected to shootings
like the one we saw in Texas precisely
well okay well a lot a lot of food for
thought for the audience certainly i am
i'm curious as to whether that that's an
idea that will resonate or surprise or
engage or i'm sure we will get feedback
from up from a number of people in our
audience but we've been speaking with
llamara we nee a former White House
correspondent and communications expert
I really appreciate you talking to me
today are you welcome Dave my pleasure